en france les fidèles ont pu assister à
la messe de noël la nuit dernière
profitant de la levée exceptionnelle du
couvre-feu instauré de 20 heures à 6
heures du matin depuis dix jours
l'italie voit de son côté les traditions
bousculer avec un énième re confinement
depuis hier et jusqu'au 27 décembre les
italiens peuvent sortir de chez eux
seulement une fois par jour les
déplacements entre régions sont aussi
interdits compliqué de rendre visite à
un proche d'autant que pour noël et la
saint sylvestre il est possible
uniquement d'inviter deux personnes à la
maison accompagnées d'enfants âgés de 14
ans maximum
en espagne le gouvernement a lui rappelé
les enjeux de ces fêtes mort vers celle
au minimum et c'est sallie déplacez-vous
le moins possible seulement ce qui est
indispensable et limiter les contacts au
maximum ces journées sont faites pour
passer du temps à la maison avec la
famille la plus proche et bouger le
moins possible parce que la situation
n'évolue pas bien et si ces jours ci
nous faisons ce que nous devons faire
alors nous aurons à partir du 27
décembre le début de la fin mais nous
avons encore un effort à faire
delfini plessis que delphine penneteau à
vienne autriche ou des espagnols mieux
loti avec des déplacements entre régions
autorisée mais des réveillons qui ne
doivent pas excéder dix personnes
enfants inclus un seul invités
extérieurs en ce qui concerne les
familles belges 2 pour les personnes
seules
la belgique qui a décalé son couvre-feu
à minuit comme la plupart des pays
européens à l'occasion de noël mais pas
d'exception en revanche pour la capitale
bruxelles 22 heures 6 heures du matin
reste la norme couvre-feu d'ailleurs
suspendu jusqu'à demain en allemagne
le but faciliter des voyages retour qui
s'annonce compliquée je me suis testé
avant et aussi en ce moment je porte de
masque j'ai gardé la distance et j'ai
pris des précautions ping pong
eh bien je me teste parce que je suis
venu en allemagne il ya quelques jours
pour retrouver ma mère et mon père qui
sont stationnés ici pour le moment j'ai
l'intention de passer noël avec eux les
autorités ont recommandé à leurs
ressortissants de s'isoler pendant une
semaine puis de passer un test kovy 19
avant de pouvoir voyager et d'accueillir
quatre personnes maximum pour dîner en
revanche l'interdiction de bouger
notamment pour les londoniens et les
habitants du sud-est de l'angleterre
confronté à une hausse des
contaminations et nouvelle variante du
virus
il ya plusieurs choses que je voulais
acheter que je n'ai pas pu trouver sur
les étagères je suis allé dans quelques
magasins et oui les choses commencent à
ralentir en termes de produits que vous
pouvez acheter
je pense que les pénuries peuvent être
dus à la perturbation dans les ports et
si ce n'est pas résolue rapidement je
pense que les gens commenceront à
paniquer un 25 décembre synonyme
d'anxiété jusqu'au 24 janvier prochain
le premier ministre danois a annoncé que
le pays sera pratiquement fermé avec
l'ouverture seulement des commerces de
première nécessité